en este vídeo sólo voy a multiplicar un
montón de polinomios y espero que eso
les dé muchísima confianza y se sientan
seguros a la hora de ustedes resolver
cualquier problema de multiplicación de
polígonos así que digamos que quiero
multiplicar 2x por 4 x menos 5 así que
simplemente utilizaremos directamente la
propiedad distributiva distributiva
perdón y todo lo que haremos es utilizar
esta propiedad repetitivamente cuando
estamos multiplicando polinomios por
ejemplo aquí tendríamos que esto es 2 x
x 4 x ok + 2 x x menos 5 pero podría
decir también que es menos 5
2x verdad simplemente lo que hice en
este paso fue hacer la propia
distributiva y multiplicó 2x por 4x y
luego 2x por menos 5 ahora 2x por 4x
simplemente puedo re a arreglar los
términos de estos 2 x 4 x x x x verdad
ahora 2 x 4 es 8 y x x x es x cuadrada
esto es porque esto es x a la 1 verdad y
al multiplicar sumamos los exponentes de
todos modos x x x ya sabes que es x
cuadrada verdad así que esto es 8 x
cuadrada menos 5 x 2 es 10 x x
nada mal vamos a hacer uno un poquito
más complicado digamos que tengo 9 x al
cubo x
3 x cuadrada menos 2 x + 7 así que otra
vez vamos a utilizar la propiedad
distributiva aquí vamos a multiplicar el
9 x al cubo por cada uno de los términos
verdad así que 9 x al cubo por 3 x al
cuadrado dejan escribirlo ya después lo
haré a lo mejor como un cálculo mental
pero ahorita vamos a escribirlo entonces
9 x al cubo por 3 x cuadrada y luego
vamos a tener más o bueno déjenme
ponerlo así menos 2 x
9 x al cubo y finalmente más 7 x 9 x al
cubo así que algunas veces escribir 9 x
al cubo por el otro a veces el otro por
9 x al cubo en realidad no hace
diferencia verdad porque el orden de los
factores no altera el producto así que
el primer término que será 9 por 3 son
27 y x al cubo por equis cuadrada se
suman los exponentes y tenemos tres más
dos son cinco menos dos por nueve que
son 18 y ahora x por x al cubo es 13
como sumo los exponentes y me da x a la
4 más 7 por 9 son 63 x al cubo así que
terminamos con este lindo polinomio de
quinto grado
ahora vamos a hacer uno donde
involucremos la multiplicación de dos
binomios
y voy a mostrarles esto en unos segundos
esto es algo que verán muy
frecuentemente en álgebra así que
digamos que tengo x 3 x x + 2 y de hecho
quiero y quiero mostrarles qué es lo que
aquí realmente utilizamos la propiedad
distributiva varias veces así que
déjenlo escribirlo con verde del lado
derecho muy bien así que vamos a vamos a
pretender que este número que estoy en
marcando esto en realidad es sólo un
número verdad así que utilizando la
propiedad distributiva sería este número
x menos 3 y multiplica a cada una de las
variables del siguiente polinomio en
este caso sería x x más este número que
es x 3 x 2
multiplicar por 2 este verde ahora todo
lo que hicimos fue distribuir este x + 2
con el factor x menos tres pero bueno
vamos a recordar en general que si yo
tengo a x x + 2 esto simplemente va a
ser
en el ponerlo con los colores apropiados
esto es por
x +
por el número 2 verdad
así que aquí justamente nuestra vale x 3
y fue justo lo que hicimos en este paso
ahora volvemos a usar la propiedad
distributiva en este caso vamos a
distribuir x con x menos 3 y el 2 con x
menos tres así que puedes ver qué es lo
que va a ir saliendo verdad entonces en
este caso déjenme déjenme poner los
colores como como van aquí va x x x
menos 3 x
x más otra vez propiedad distributiva x
x
ok esto ya está un poquito el plato
sopero es menos 3 por 2 muy bien
simplemente lo que utilizamos fue la
propiedad distributiva aquí y bueno
quizás después lo hagas en un solo paso
aquí estamos multiplicando término por
perú por término para que quede más
claro pero porque lo que realmente
quiero es que quede clara la idea así
que x x x es x cuadrada aquí tenemos
menos 3 x aquí tenemos más 2 x y aquí
tenemos menos 6 verdad ahora
esto es x cuadrada y menos 3 x 2 x
simplemente es menos que x
-6 simplemente sumamos estos últimos a
los dos de enmedio verdad entonces
simplemente ya con este ejemplo ya no
tengo que hacer todos estos pasos ya
vimos claramente cómo utilizar la
propiedad distributiva la forma fácil o
la forma rápida de hacerlo es si tienes
x menos 3 x x + 2
literalmente multiplicas cada término x
entre todos así que aquí por ejemplo es
x x x es x cuadrada luego x x 2 es 2x
luego menos 3 x x es menos 3 x menos 3 x
es menos 6 verdad y que es justamente ya
simplificando es x cuadrada menos x
menos 6 entonces como viste bueno toma
un poquito de práctica para tomar este
para poder hacerlo de esta forma pero
bueno esto nos ahorra un poco en tiempo
verdad
ahora vamos a multiplicar un binomio por
un trinomio ok
quizás mucha gente para asustarlos pero
aquí no aquí somos valientes digamos que
tengo el 3 x + 2 x 9 x cuadrada menos 6
x + 4 ahora podrías hacerlo exactamente
como lo hicimos en esta última parte
tomamos 3 x + 2 y vas multiplicando a
cada uno de los términos y después vas a
distribuir cada uno de los términos por
3 x + 2 verdad pero bueno vamos a
obtener la misma respuesta
cuando cuando tienes polinomios más
grandes la forma más fácil de pensar
cómo multiplicarlos es simplemente
vamos a escribirlo de esta forma por
ejemplo 9 x cuadrada menos 6 x 4 y vamos
a multiplicar 3 x + 2 que es más o menos
como cuando multiplicamos números
ok es más o menos lo mismo tomamos un
lugar para las centenas luego para las
escenas y luego para las unidades aquí
vamos a tomar lugares para las equis
cuadradas para las equis normales o para
los números xin xin xin x digamos así
que vamos a empezar aquí vamos a hacer
como una multiplicación tradicional 2
por 4 es 8 luego
aquí vamos a dejar la columna de las
constancias ahora multiplicamos a 2 x
menos 6 x
ok 2 x menos 6 x eso es menos 12 x aquí
ponemos menos 12 x
y entonces vamos a ponerle el masaje al
8 y luego 2 por 9 x cuadrada esto
simplemente es 18 x cuadrado
ahora vamos a hacer la parte con 3 x
vamos a ver cómo esto es diferente
porque 3x por 4 3 x por 4 es 12 x y lo
ponemos en la columna donde están solo
las x ahora 3x x menos 6 x esto
simplemente es 3 por 6 es menos 18
bueno aquí es aquí es x cuadrado verdad
x x x y luego 3 x menos 6 es menos 18
muy bien ahora 3x por 9 x cuadradas
simplemente es x x x cuadrada es x al
cubo y 3 por 9 es 27
solo lo escribí en una columna parte que
es la correspondiente a las equis
cúbicas y ahora sumamos esto es 8 aquí
menos 12 x + 2x se cancelan y 18 menos
18 x cuadradas se cancelan verdad y
simplemente nos queda 27 x al cubo así
que esto es igual a 27 x al cubo más 8 y
ya hemos acabado así que puedes utilizar
esta técnica para multiplicar binomios
trinomios polinomios muy grandes no
importan quizás de grado 5 esto siempre
va a funcionar siempre y cuando tengas
todo bajo su propia columna